[Music]
okay everybody this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 1 cold snap
this was directed by marco sega and
written by clyde phillips which is super
important because clyde phillips was the
showrunner of seasons one through four
aka the great seasons of dexter and you
see how much the quality dropped off
from the final seasons here when he left
so it was exciting to see that he is the
showrunner for this
full 10 episodes of this season and you
can see already the difference and how
it feels like the dexter of old that was
before the fall off of quality for the
show it makes all the difference who you
have helming behind the scenes here and
who's writing here so really exciting
that clyde phillips is here and he
hasn't lost his touch so where we catch
up with dexter here it's about 10 years
later from where we last saw him and now
he's under the identity of jim lindsey
and he's running through this snowy
environment in the woods in upstate new
york he's going after this white buck
and it's important because he's not able
to shoot this white book it's so
interesting with his character of dexter
where you see by the end of this episode
you know he's pissed when the bucket
shot because he sees it as innocent he's
not this guy who can just hunt these
innocent animals that's not dexter even
though he's a serial killer it's not in
his dna and he's trying to but he can't
which is fascinating which we get more
into but you see it's playing in this
opening scene he pops the passenger
which was also played in the trailer a
little on the nose because of his dark
passenger we all know and love about
dexter but it actually is something i
think in this type of show we can get
away with it fits with the style of the
show so i don't actually get mad about
that in this type of show i think that
song works perfectly for the type of
genre we're in here with dexter i really
like it being in this snowy environment
and it being a color palette of all this
cold blue because i was sick of the
miami scene for dexter even in season
four i was over it i thought this just
stayed there way too long so i'm happy
seeing dexter in a new fresh area i
appreciate that and i appreciate what
this intro episode did so well and a
couple of things that really stood out
to me is that they winked at stuff from
dexter in the past but they didn't use
it as a crutch it wasn't just uh let's
revisit things and just have nostalgia
it was its own entity and fresh enough
which i appreciated and i'll get into
why i felt like it was a lot of fresh
things happening here and i also really
loved how
they made the choice not to drag out the
whole season to get to be dexter we know
that is a killer that they could have
really slowed this down if they wanted
to and maybe made it like we don't see
it till the end but we know it's coming
so just give it to us now right that's
what makes the show run so they don't
waste time which i appreciated but what
i loved about this premiere is how when
we meet this character of matt who the
second you knew he walked into this
fish and game shop that he was this
unlikable guy that was going to be
dexter's first kill so props the actor
for being so hateable here but that they
slowly ramped up dexter's rage towards
him and that it worked so well in this
episode to eventually get that breaking
point for him and that it wasn't just
happening on a dime that it was just
earned and that you're seeing his urges
he's been trying to control and how
tempted he was this whole episode the
more and more and how he was trying to
get away from it and every time someone
was bringing up something matt did he
was trying to be like oh let's go line
dance or something like that so i
thought they did a really good job with
that and like everyone predicted but i'm
happy it's the case is that we knew
jennifer carpenter who plays deb and
she's a brilliant actress was going to
be in the season everyone predicted well
how do you do that if she's dead well
she is the new harry here and i love
that this is the case i love that they
didn't use harry here because that would
have felt redundant that would have felt
like okay we've seen this 100 times
before with dexter and honestly there's
things when you go and rewatch dexter
that are so dated now when you watch it
today so they smartly cut a lot of the
dated stuff like even the actor of harry
it's no offense to him but he even comes
off dated if that makes sense his way
he's doing the portrayal of harry feels
dated that's what i mean by that and
that the lighting on him it's like an
angel glow like it seems so cheesy now a
day so they did a good job having
jennifer carpenter here do debra as his
kind of voice talking to him which is
really his voice but it's what he thinks
deborah would be saying in that moment
and you want to have jennifer carpenter
in the show she's such a vital part of
dexter the show and his character so
it's such a smart decision and why that
makes it fresh though and not just like
her filling hairy shoes it's complete
opposite where harry was telling dexter
to be accepting of who he is to control
that he's always gonna be a killer and
that he is a killer but deborah believes
in him and it's fitting to deborah like
she's like no you don't have to be this
way commit to the routine and that's why
she gets upset when he does fall into
his urges and he she sees a better
version of dexter that harry really
didn't and that could be you know maybe
harry's right maybe he isn't that's kind
of the story of dexter here as we learn
about his character so it does make a
fresh voice that is like anti what
dexter is doing as a serial killer where
harry was supportive in a sense he just
had to follow a code now when we talk
about the wink wink moments that are the
stuff we know and love from dexter like
him bringing donuts to his job him
saying his classic line on this one i'm
basically switzerland i love to hear
that and they had nice little touches of
lines here where you know he says to
matt i haven't killed an animal since i
was a teenager which is the truth
remember in season one in a flashback we
saw as a teenager he killed the
neighbor's dog of course being a sign of
a serial killer here but he hasn't since
and he doesn't in this episode either
where they kind of lead you that way
like he's going to but he can't he it's
not him and we meet his love interest
now which is angela bishop she's the
chief of police in this town and you see
dexter still can't quit being around
crime being around the law and it goes
too you can't quit you know he's working
in a fish and game shop with guns and
knives around him so as much as he was
saying he was like being a different
person for 10 years he really is doing
the worst things you can do for someone
if you want to compare it to like
addiction you know you shouldn't be
around guns and knives then if you're a
serial killer you shouldn't be around
the police station honestly where you
used to work so it's something that he
wasn't fully ever recovered from being a
serial killer you're putting yourself in
that situation like to just let's say
relapse it's like again like an
alcoholic just yeah you know i'm i've
been drinking 10 years but i still hang
around bars all the time you know it's a
recipe for disaster here so they did a
good job of kind of showing you that
that he wasn't fully over those things
just little things too seeing the
butcher here how he just gets that like
craving when he sees all that blood it's
fascinating they did such a good job
with that and they didn't overdo it and
they did a good job reminding you of
like dexter morgan here his killings and
what he does he has that superhero arc
where we know so well that he's doing it
for justice so him being around people
telling him what matt really did at the
end of the day with this boat and
killing these people because he was
wasted you know it's gonna set him off
this is what causes him to kill he wants
to get rid of these bad people and his
way of doing it is killing which is his
kind of passion you know and his drug
and it makes sense then why he doesn't
kill this white bucket he has this
moment he reaches his hand out because
he doesn't want to kill the innocent you
know that's not dexter at the end of the
day so it did a really good job with
that and getting that feeling of like oh
now you're on dexter's side again too
because he's not shooting this white
buck he's killing this guy who's so
hateable again and this character of
matt what they did a good job with the
writing here is we see there's this
mysterious figure watching in the
episode turns out it's harrison and
that's what's interesting too
about the finale of dexter as a whole
that it did actually leave some open
threads so it's not like this feels
force it wasn't this tight bow of the
finale of dexter there was things that
are left to explore with dexter but also
with his son so they kind of lucked out
with that that they can explore that
with harrison and even what's going on
with hannah which will be interesting to
see if they bring yvonne strahovsky back
which would be awesome because i love
her as an actress shout out handmaid's
tale but you know it's interesting that
what they did here to set up how
harrison feels like dexter's or has
ditched him which is true but deb's like
no you heard everyone you love don't go
near him and then he decides you know
what i'm gonna end this episode he's
going the hairy way when harryway is
killing by the code and addressing
what's there and dealing with it head-on
and seems like dexter's assuming
obviously that harrison's got his blood
he's the only true blood son of dexter
and that he would have this serial
killer tendency so he's like you know
what i'm gonna do what harry did for me
protect me show me the way so it's
different than what deb would want and
he knows that in his head but he's going
with what harry's saying and but what
i'm saying about the writing and setting
that up really well or tied with the
main story well is having that
conversation when he eventually kills
matt that you know matt saying he didn't
have a good childhood and parents that
treat him horribly basically didn't have
the guidance and dexter relating to that
but saying harry was his guide so it
kind of puts in his mind too at that
point again maybe i should go and be a
father figure to my son harrison so he
doesn't feel betrayed and go down a
darker hole than he possibly could
without dexter's guidance but my
favorite thing this premiere did more
than anything was you're sitting there
wondering huh you know like this is a
full dexter episode we're gonna get with
none of dexter's narration that's such a
prime integral part of this show it's
based off the book so it kind of runs
like a book where you're hearing his
thoughts which makes it so exciting and
i love they made it seem like we weren't
and then they gave you that reward and
it's when he breaks and becomes the
dexter we know and love when he's like
okay if we're gonna do this we're gonna
do it right i loved it he's bringing up
the code again that was such an awesome
payoff and revealed that okay we're back
we're really here now in dexter's shoes
he's doing his narration and we see
michael c hall hasn't lost his step as
dexter he absolutely crushes which is
expected but he was so good especially
when he broke here and his scene and
like i said i i wish i had wrote down
the actor's name who deserves to hear
his name but the actor of matt you know
really kills it here like people would
say well maybe he's over acting in this
scene but he's not like that's what
you're doing when you're on your your
death table here with dexter and to keep
up with michael c hall as a tribute to
him and that's a props to the casting in
this episode and that also goes to the
actor of harrison here his son because
harrison if you're bringing in a teen
character you always worry and you got
to make sure so people don't get annoyed
by that character they get frustrating
that's a really good actor and harrison
has already shown the actor that he's
really good here too so i'm really happy
and relieved that they're casting good
actors around michael c hall and like i
said you're still getting the decks you
love but they're giving it freshness
like just a little thing here where you
know we see like he always did he's
cutting the cheek and keeping that blood
as a trophy but he's like you know what
i may be a monster but i'm an evolve
monster so he's not doing that anymore
so again giving us what we know but
making a fresh take on it and evolving
the character like he's saying he's
evolved monster so hopefully they keep
down that route and it's gonna be
interesting that happens now with him
and deb because deb's like why are you
doing this you're not listening to me
he's like i'm not listening to you at
all anymore and so this is gonna be a
conflict there again i'm hoping they
don't bring harry back as a flash
because again i feel like it will feel
too redundant and dated again no dis to
the actor but his portrayal of the
character and the way they showed him
was very dated if you rewatch it so i'd
rather them stick to deborah here and
who wouldn't want more of jennifer
carpenter you know it's a reason to keep
her on the show and it leaves interest
here of like what is harrison gonna be
like is dexter making the wrong call
maybe harrison is completely normal you
know so is this a bad idea to bring
harrison close to him like deborah's
saying we're gonna have to see they set
up little seeds for the season like him
killing matt and matt bringing up his
father who's this powerful man rich man
in the town so that's going to be
something that's going to follow dexter
and him maybe trying to figure out who
killed his son obviously and they set up
stuff with angela then angela's a mom so
his love interest angela having a
daughter is going to also be important
for dexter and that's going to add more
complications to that relationship and
you see dexter doing those you know
things that's awful that happens within
his life from doing all these killings
is that now here we go he's lying again
where she's calling him like where are
you at this christmas gathering and he's
got to make up where he is this is
classic dexter and this is his downfall
and he just loses the normal life as he
does these killings and things that he
loves so that's the tough thing and what
clearly where deborah's right and you
see with dexter he even mentions to matt
that he's a little rusty here with the
killing and his setup but they did leave
a little cliffhanger here too at the end
episode where there's a blood trail to
his killing shack so i don't know if i'm
looking too much into that but i think
that is a case where he because of his
rust you know he he's already leaving a
blood trail of what he's done so it's
going to see what happens there and that
you know he hasn't done this for about
10 years so we'll see if he can even do
this well anymore but you know i thought
this was a great premiere it's a lot of
setup but they took their time in a slow
pace that really worked and that you got
the payoffs for it and that it was
realistic and that again the main thing
was it didn't feel like do we need to be
here or do we need to do this you know
revival of dexter i felt like no we do
need to be here this is justified and
this is really good and you're seeing
like what happens is you bring back the
showrunner that worked and you see the
magic that happens it's pretty simple
the other day with that right like oh
what's the writer that had the best
season the dexter let's bring him back
it's probably the only reason michael c
hall did it and it works between the two
of them they work together you have
jennifer carpenter can't go wrong and
they show they're ready to do a fresh
take on it so i'm excited for this to
come i'm giving this one a 9.1 let me
know down below what you thought of it
i'd love to hear your thoughts i will be
reviewing every episode of dexter so
make sure to subscribe i'm excited to
talk to you guys about this leave your
theories down below where you think this
might go what you saw the episode i read
every comment try to respond as many as
i can and if you really love what i do
here please become a member you can join
button right there down below you'll get
exclusive stuff for signing up and it'll
help support me to do this full time one
day and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram and now tick
tock as well you can get clips from my
interviews and reviews and i'll see you
next time